hey guys I'm Brent rose tech writer and
pendulous marsupial now you may have
been hearing about powdered alcohol it
was just recently approved for sale in
the u.s. despite that a lot of states
have already gone ahead and banned it
outright
why because people are afraid they're
upstanding children will be sneaking
this highly concentrated booze powder
into Sunday school spiking each other's
juice boxes and snorting lines of it off
each other's genitals which would be
terrible if it weren't almost certainly
completely impossible so today we're
gonna be whipping up a batch of our own
we're gonna see if we can get drunk on
it we're gonna see if these concerns of
any basis in reality we're gonna see
really if you should be giving a at
all about powdered alcohol so we don't
know exactly how the commercial version
of this stuff is gonna be made the best
working theory came from our friends
over at pops I who posited that it would
be a neutral grain spirit and a tapioca
maltodextrin now this stuff is really
interesting it's been used in molecular
gastronomy because it's really really
powdery super absorbent let's whip up a
batch
[Music]
so if you remember we used 30 grams
which is just over an ounce of 151 proof
spirit which is about two drinks worth
thank you so here we have our two drinks
basically you're getting a 10 percent
ABV drinks like a really weak wine or a
really strong beer let's chug these and
see if we can get a buzz it was like
drinking bread water let's make some
more well a spoonful of sugar and red
dye makes the medicine go down Oh God
my body is never gonna forgive me for
this so we noticed there's a lot of
stuff accumulating on the sides which
makes us think I should probably drink
it
screw it oh so toxic just keeps getting
worse was a vulcanized flavor
so it's been about 20 minutes since my
last drink I feel disgusting
got a light buzz going on but my stomach
just feels like it's full of glue let's
move on to the two things that people
are really really concerned about
spiking and snorting so spiking a drink
for this we're gonna try to use the
exact same volume that the commercial
version will have let's put it in the
baggy
we'll see how easy it is spike a drink i
slurring my words maybe so this is 29
grams or what will be one drinks worth
of powdered alcohol in the consumer of
orange and the consumer version it comes
out good so we've got two Cola beverages
here dark they should mask color changes
there's no ice in them add it in let's
stir somebody stepped away from the bar
or is looking the other direction some
evildoers trying to put about an ounce
of alcohol into their drink which let's
be realistic here that's already pretty
stupid you're not worried about somebody
spiking your drink with alcohol you're
worried about somebody putting roofies
in your drink which dissolve pretty much
instantly and our tiny I've been
stirring for about a minute now you can
see there's still pretty big chunks in
there okay it's now been five minutes my
wrist is killing me even if the
commercial version dissolves twice as
fast there's just no way that anybody
would go through this and let's trouble
to spike a drink with an ounce of
alcohol by comparison here's an ounce of
alcohol spiked why wouldn't you just use
the liquid version there's no
conceivable reason to use powder for
this nefarious purpose
that's it I'm still gonna drink it
[Music]
so snorting the number one concern that
people raise is that kids are gonna
snort this stuff and get instantaneously
super drunk I'm here to tell you now
there's absolutely no way that's
possible here's why this is one drink
you would have to snort all of this to
get the alcohol of one single drink so
I'm by no means an expert on this sort
of thing but my understanding is that a
typical line is about a tenth of a gram
each of these lines here is about half a
gram so these are gigantic lines you
would have to do these 30 lines to get
half a shot of alcohol you can't believe
I'm about to do this for the sake of
science this is like one tenth of a line
here me okay yep it's a it
instantly burns behind my eyeball I can
already feel that side of my nose
closing up burning all the way over into
the other side of my nostril now yeah
yeah I'm okay oh god so that little bit
that I did sucked I would have to do six
hundred times that amount to get one
shot of alcohol in me when I could just
take the shot
even if somehow a person were able to
get a full line into each nostril your
nose would just close up after that
there's just no possible way that kids
are gonna do this there's no way I'm
sneezing like crazy Oh God
so what if anything did we learn here
today I had about four drinks made with
powdered alcohol it got me a little bit
buzzed we learned that spiking
somebody's drink with it is totally
impractical and we certainly realized
that snorting it is ill-advised stupid
and completely inefficient all that
being said can you imagine a use case
where this would actually be a useful
thing let us know what you think in the
comments below subscribe to Wired if you
haven't already for more videos like
this and with all that being said you
only got one thing left to do
[Music]
so what was the plan there yeah we were
we were going for a big elaborate flame
ball and it didn't quite hit
[Music]
[Applause]